they cancelled john rowling recently the
child the children's author her books
are published all over the world even
just because she didn't satisfy the
demands of gender rights they're not
trying to cancel our country i'm talking
about the progressive discrimination of
everything to do with russia this trend
that's unfolding in a number of western
states
with the full um
neglect sometimes encouragement of
western cultures
that they're now
engaging in the council culture they're
even removing tchaikovsky
rachmaninov from uh
posters russian writers and their books
are
cancelled there's now
the latest
program to cancel
world literature was conducted by the
nazis in germany 90 years
years ago we remember those that that
footage when they were burning books
it's impossible to imagine such a thing
in our country
and we're insured against this thanks to
our
culture and it's inseparable for us from
our motherland from russia where there
is no place for ethnic intolerance where
for centuries
representatives from dozens of ethnic
groups have been living together and
cultural diversity is the pride of our
society the strength and priority of our
states